[Music]
[Applause]
watch this quick release coming back he
knows he's got a bigger man on him that
that's just quick-release driving kick
has worked for Washington in the early
going they're getting good looks
[Music]
[Applause]
go with ricochet
snapped his captured suit
[Applause]
is he clear together yes
[Applause]
let me show you
now Steph has 11 points in the last
minute
[Applause]
let's go bikini
[Applause]
counted did collegiate teams I've ever
seen curry have not scored this quarter
[Applause]
[Music]
and he'll smell that Gary
[Applause]
play
but who hit sell and they watch Markieff
Morris well then oh boy you're right
because Bradley Beal came right under
Stephon curry
[Applause]
[Applause]
from Washington that's the thing though
did I see Paul's not moving for them
they evil must be greater than 2 it is
my unlimited range why isn't someone
crowding him making foot on the floor I
know it should go in but this suffering
that
[Applause]
[Music]
eighteen indicator
he is worth the price of admission